all right my name is Alice Boxhall I'm a
developer on the chrome accessibility
team I have a bit of a cold so I'm sorry
if I'm a little hole feel that's cool I
didn't need to use my slides all right
so I'll get into the guts of my talk in
a second but I just really like this
definition of accessibility that you can
find on good on Wikipedia accessibility
is the degree to which a product device
service or environment is available to
as many people as possible and what I
like about this is it doesn't make any
reference to ability or disability it
includes people who are in a hurry it
includes people who are using a mobile
device it includes people who find small
click targets really really irritating
and to make it more explicit I think
that accessibility actually implies
multi device because you're making your
product accessible to people in a wide
variety of situations and for a wide
variety of backgrounds so today I'm
going to talk about what inaccessibility
looks like so the types of patterns and
things that are going to make your site
inaccessible to various groups of people
I'm gonna introduce screen readers if
anyone who's never experienced a screen
reader I'm going to give a demo and
explain how you can try out a screen
reader yourself I'll talk about what you
can do to improve the accessibility of
your site how to assess the
accessibility of your site and then I'll
have some links at the end for more
information all right so what is
inaccessibility look like what
constitutes inaccessibility well here's
a good example anyone seen this on a
mobile device or even their computer
yeah it sucks right so this is what it's
like when you cannot access something so
different users are going to require
different things obviously so we have a
bunch of different groups that we need
to consider low vision hearing impaired
or deaf low motor ability so this is
someone they can range from like having
a tremor or having poor motor control
through to having no use of your hands
at all screenreader or Braille display
use are so this could I'll get more into
that later and voice control user so
this is the extreme end of lack of motor
ability and in almost all cases
accommodating these needs improves the
experience for everybody so who are the
users that we're addressing here so 9.2
percent of the adult population of the
US more in developing countries have
some vision trouble so the way that you
address this is very simple avoid low
contrast text because really who likes
reading low contrast text anyway avoid
relying on color alone for communication
make sure that the text is resizable and
we saw in the mobile took earlier that's
really useful anyway provide text
alternatives for visual media and again
this is really useful if say you don't
want to watch a video to get the only
documentation for that devtool you'd
really like to use so thirty-six point
four million adults in the US have at
least one complex activity limitation so
this is motor control this this a person
may not be able to use a mouse for
example or may have like significant
trouble accessing small clip targets so
provide large click targets lower your
radio buttons if I need to use one more
form where the radio buttons aren't
labeled and I have to click on that tiny
tiny circle I may actually flip my table
ensure your site can be used with the
keyboard only and this is something that
I'm going to return to time and time
again because this will actually get you
a really long way to making us at
accessible for the broadest range of
users so screen reader and Braille users
are a much smaller number from the point
of view of web author you guys these
groups are largely interchangeable even
though the way they access the page is
gonna be slightly different especially
in the case of screen reader users they
may or might actually be may or may not
actually be blind they may have another
impairment such as dyslexia or learning
disability they may not be able to read
they may not be able to read the target
language they may be temporarily unable
to read such as like recovering from
laser surgery such as getting motion
sick that kind of thing but by and large
things remember
these is without assistive technology
they're not going to be able to access
the site at all so this is the flash
situation all right so screen readers
the way that a user with the screen
reader is going to be interacting with
the device the screen reader or Braille
display is going to translate the
interface of the other site into text or
speech so in this case we can imagine
the interface has like a cancel button
an OK button it's going to read out
cancel button the user is going to then
hit a keyboard shortcut and so with
desktop screen readers there are
literally hundreds of keyboard shortcuts
to make navigating really really
efficient so they're gonna go to the
next control it reads out ok button then
they hit another keyboard shortcut to
send a click command so instead of using
the mouse they're going to be using
interacting by the screen reader and
then it's going to tell them that the
button has been clicked all right so I
have this is a demo of chromebox which
is a screen reader for chrome and Chrome
OS it's built into Chrome OS and I'll
get to how to use it in a minute but
I'll just show you this first home list
item sessions link list item schedule
link visited list item clicked chrome
dev summit 2013 navigation list with
three items find in page and multi Multi
multi device accessibility link visited
press ENTER to accept the exited find
and pay chrome dev summit 2013 tab
alright so that was just me going
through the chrome dev summit site
earlier with query box and finding my
orientation
yeah all right so chromebox is built
specifically for the web it's built in
on Chrome OS you can activate it anytime
on Chrome OS and the really nice feature
of it is that it's really easy to use
for sighted users a lot of screen
readers that are dedicated for use by
blind people don't have any kind of
visual feedback they're really difficult
to learn the keyboard shortcuts for you
really need a lot of training but
chromevox can be picked up by a beginner
in about a minute all right so my
estimate is 30 seconds it's probably a
bit of a level so as I said keyboard
shortcuts really dry screen readers so
we have a set of modifier keys we can
refer to as C box you can configure it
it can defaults to controller on windows
gnu/linux control command on OS X and
search shift on Chrome OS and in Chrome
OS you can turn it on at any time or
turn it off with control Z and chromebox
AAA or temporarily turn the chrome box
feed back on or off if you have the
extension installed in Chrome okay so
the way you actually use it this is the
way I will test things for accessibility
as extremely novice screen reader user
so use the chrome box keys and up and
down to navigate through the page so
this is what I was doing in the demo a
minute ago current vault space will
force a click so that this is how you
click things we need to have a mouse
control by itself
we'll make chrome bug stop talking if
anyone's curious what this search
command I use is actually chromebox
forward slash so on mobile devices the
story's a little bit different obviously
you're not going to have a keyboard
you're not gonna have all these hundreds
of keyboard shortcuts but what you do
have is a touch screen so what they will
do is use their finger to touch the
screen and explore okay explore the
screen and it will read out whatever
they have touched so in this case we can
imagine a user exploring the same
interface I really don't know what that
sound is sorry
exploring the interface finding a button
an OK button and it counts the button
and this time they've clicked the cancel
button so talkback is built-in on all
Android devices you can turn it on from
the accessibility settings if you want
to try it out so then you'll get a short
tutorial on how to use the touch
exploration feature like I was just
talking about so yet
and in this case double tapping will
send I think it's actually a click event
but it's it may as well be a touch event
and that will allow the user actually
interact with things on Android you also
have Braille back this needs to be
installed from the Play Store but that
will allow the Android device to pair
with a Braille device so what I've shown
here is looking at the chrome dev summit
site using Braille back and with the
on-screen Braille display to simulate
what the Braille Braille device will
display so you can see that it it's
pretty similar to the spoken feedback
except it will have all these
abbreviations so that it can fit more
information into a shorter space alright
so what can you actually do to improve
the accessibility of your site start off
with the design design with diverse uses
in mind so when you're looking at how to
create your interactions think about how
keyboard-only user would interact with
the app don't assume that someone's
going to be able to perform a hover
interaction and in fact someone on a
phone is probably not gonna be able to
perform all of our interaction either
how the screen reader users are going to
interact with your site so this means
you need to think about what the text
alternative what the label is for
everything what's going to be read out
when you are focused on a particular
element is it just gonna say div do you
have images without alt text that kind
of thing and finally how dr. Liu is your
interface if something is viewed via
some kind of assistive device or viewed
maybe by a text only device is it going
to work or is it just going to fail
horribly
so again ensure that you have a good
keyboard only user experience what does
this actually look like firstly I
shouldn't need to say this but you
standard
wherever possible they come with
built-in screen built-in keyboard
handling so the polymer talk yesterday
went a bit into what you get for free
with standard elements user extend good
custom elements with built-in keyboard
controls so when you can't use standard
widgets or you want something that looks
a bit different or behaves a bit
differently use good custom elements or
write your own good custom elements with
keyboard handling so I'll get into what
you need to do and to roll it yourself
in a minute alright so if you're writing
your own elements whether you using
custom elements or whether you're just
writing noting something from scratch
use tab index that'll make things
focusable so if you have something which
is a quick target that isn't focusable
screen reader may actually have if it
difficulties using it plus someone who's
Kiba only will never be able to use it I
assume you all know how to use tab index
so I won't get into that and handle
keyboard events wherever you handle
click or touch events and if you want to
know which key word which keys to listen
for follow established user experience
patterns for the platform that you're
targeting alright this is something we
may not necessarily think of that is
actually really irritating if you're
trying to use an app keyboard only
manage focus so make sure that focus is
in a sensible order with the with the
tab image property make focus visible so
you don't make your user play and find
the focused element so what does that
game look like it looks like this I'm
sorry to pick on Gmail
that's just that use demo all the time
and this really bugs me where's the
focus here you can see if you really
squint it's actually right there if
you're showing a pop-up or a modal
dialog and so on move focus within the
pop-up when you open it so your call
focus from JavaScript and we're focused
back to the element that triggered the
pop-up on clothes so I've clicked my
focus element or a breast endo and it's
sure to pop up so that's good it had
keyboard handling now is focus
it is actually in the pop-up so that's
cool however now when I close the pop-up
it goes to a random location in Gmail
that I haven't actually figured out what
the logic is yet okay next step Express
the semantics of your interface so as I
keep saying you standard widgets are
ever possible because they're gonna have
the semantics built in or use well
written custom elements which are
handling this for you and again if
you're writing your own custom elements
or you're writing things from scratch
use Aria to express the semantics
alright so this is a non semantic
interface it's a div that has an on
click event one click listener this is
much better it's a button that still
hasn't unclick listener but it's gonna
actually have a tabindex now it's going
to respond to keyboard events and we
have a custom element sort of that we've
given an aria role so that's now going
to also be presented to a screen reader
as a button but that's not really the
whole story you still need to make it
first of all and handle key events so
what's REO this are anything that I keep
talking about the stands for accessible
rich Internet applications
it's a w3c standard and it allows you to
express role states and properties for
elements by our HTML attributes so we
saw this role attribute that's a Aria
attribute so what that does the reason I
keep going on about semantics is that
screen readers are all about semantics
it's not it's going to view a modified
version of the Dom that just tells it
what the role and what the text is for
each element is not interested in images
it's not interested in layout and so you
see here is we've applied a role to this
div and an aria label which is an array
property and that gets rendered to the
screen reader as an actual button and
allows the user to interact with this as
if it was an actual button okay
Thanks presently here we have a native
button and as we saw in the polymer talk
yesterday this comes out looking like a
button and it comes out interact with a
sari with a JavaScript Dom object which
allows you to access all the attributes
you would expect for a button it also
comes out with an accessibility tree
which is mangled because reasons that
tells the screen reader that as a button
and it has a press statement on pristy
and so on for custom elements you need
to do a little more work so that in this
case the customer element author has
made it so that the custom element will
write these Aria role and attribute when
the custom element is rendered to the
page so then we end up with a similar
situation as we do for native elements
where we have a visual rendering we have
a Dom object that lets us access the
attributes that we want and interact
with them and get a good developer
experience but also have an excess
accessibility tree which makes sense to
a screen reader or Braille display user
okay so how can you actually assess the
accessibility of your site firstly try
it without a mouse try it without a
trackpad I saw this great tweet from
someone saying the trackpad on my
macbook air broke and I'm on a plane to
old site developers area please fix your
accessibility try out a screen reader
the way you use the screen reader will
not be the same as the way it
experienced screen reader users usually
uses it but it will give you an idea of
what things are labeled what things are
accessible by the screen reader when
focus has gone horribly wrong that kind
of thing it's worth just trying it out
and you can also do automated testing so
there's this extension for Chrome called
accessibility developer tools and it's
also a JavaScript library so you can use
it in your continuous testing and I'll
give you a demonstration of that
all right so it's in the comes up in the
audits tab yep
comes off in the audits tab of their
developer tools so you it just comes up
here I've run it already on this page
obviously and it's come up with a couple
of many errors for this page couple I'd
like to highlight so we have this idiot
it says it's unfortunately cropped by
the page but it says these elements are
focusable
but either invisible or obscured by
another element so what's happened here
is we have focusable elements that are
behind this modal dialog which for a
screen reader users are going to come up
as completely visible even though to a
sighted user
they obviously inaccessible it's going
to be a really confusing experience and
what we want to do is make sure that
everything that is hidden behind this
dialog has an aria can attribute which
will hide it from a screen reader you
possibly also want to set the tab index
to negative one to make sure that it's
not part of the tab water and then here
we have a it says text elements should
have a reasonable contrast ratio so I
was talking earlier about users with low
vision or even just anyone using a
mobile device in bright sunlight low
contrast X is a real pain and so I'll
just demonstrate a neat feature that it
has which is that I can look at this in
the elements panel and it'll actually
come up with suggestions for colors I
could use instead so yeah it's slightly
darker and much darker and finally so
here I think that's always bugged me
about using Aria is that when you write
incorrect HTML the dev tools are going
to tell you it's gonna come up as a
error when you write incorrect Aria you
just sort of like you really have no
feedback until you try using it with a
screen reader and discover that it
doesn't work so here we have a progress
bar and I'll show you what's actually
happened so I've tried to set the value
to 80% but a tenth that Aria value now
takes a number instead of a string so
when I try and view that with chromebox
actually you know I can't do that
um anyway when I try to view that with
Korean books it actually says progress
not on number of percent which is really
embarrassing so I can actually fix that
and now it's telling me that it's
correct all right so just to sum up
improving accessibility will almost
always improve the experience everyone
even when you're looking at screen
reader accessibility what you're doing
is expressing your interface more
semantically which will improve the
maintainability and testability of your
code there are testing tools that
actually look at the accessibility tree
in order to create interaction tests
keep diverse users in mind at all stages
of development so when you're designing
when you're building your interface when
you're testing make sure that you're
testing the interactions that anyone
would use have a good keyboard only
story if you do one thing please do that
express your interface semantically as
well as visually I think I've covered
that use automated and manual
accessibility testing so I yeah
demonstrated a bit of how to do both of
those and finally listen to your users
if you have users filing accessibility
bugs follow up with them figure out
what's going wrong and finally we have
some links so a bunch of screen readers
that you can try demonstrated chromebox
there's also a screen reader built into
and I showed you some screenshots of
talkback there are screen readers built
into every Mac Mac desktop and iOS
device which is voice over so you can
use that as well a few other ones so
these are all free a bunch of them are
open-source and so as much as we were
ragging on the web content accessibility
guidelines they're actually worth a read
the W AR AR spec is there the
accessibility developer tools extension
and library there you can also search
for them on Google they're pretty high
up in the search results and that's all
I have thanks